estamos aqui novamente para uma live
fantástica sobre hidrogênio a Live
anterior foi um sucesso então resolvi
fazer uma nova Live agora com a presença
ilustre do Marcelo Nonato que vai
engrandecer essa Live vai nos prestar o
seus depoimentos muito interessantes as
experiências que ele
teve com o hidrogênio Então a gente vai
ter aqui uma combinação muito
interessante estamos agora ao vivo
também no Instagram então você pode
acompanhar essa Live no YouTube que eu
recomendo ou acompanhar no Instagram ok
deixe a sua mensagem o seu Boa noite a
sua saudação e também a sua pergunta nós
vamos nos alternar aqui falando
informações relevantes importantes sobre
o hidrogênio e eh Vamos responder as
perguntas à medida do possível e a gente
vai alternar fazer essa dinâmica bem
interessante de alternar entre
informação muito útil para vocês e
responder as melhores perguntas bem eu
Saúdo Marcelo Nonata é um prazer muito
grande ele estar aqui com a gente ele
também já vai se apresentar e vai contar
um pouco da história pessoal dele eu
tenho certeza que ele vai agregar muito
a nossa Live mas antes vamos falar
rapidamente sobre o que é o hidrogênio
molecular el é uma substância que tem
despertado muito interesse na comunidade
científica tá na moda vamos dizer assim
as pessoas estão muito falando sobre
esse assunto no meio científico isso
porque tem Grandes propriedades grande
potencial terapêutico o hidrogênio é o
elemento mais leve e simples da Tabela
Periódica ele é fundamental paraa vida
na terra está presente na composição de
quase todas as moléculas orgânicas a
simplicidade do hidrogênio e a leveza
dele conferem a capacidade de atravessar
praticamente todas as barreiras
biológicas no meu caso da membrana
celular então ele é um excelente
antioxidante não tem
são a passagem por ser uma molécula
muito pequena uma das menores da
natureza e na verdade o hidrogênio é o
que é o grande combustível do Sol e é a
molécula mais fundamental uma das
primeiras que foram formadas em toda a
criação né do universo então o
hidrogênio consegue alcançar o interior
o núcleo das células consegue alcançar
as mitocôndrias exerce então efeitos
maravilhosos e benéficos em 2020 foi
publicado um livro chamado hidrogênio
molecular para cinaa pela Editora
Springer é uma obra Pioneira de um autor
chamado Y fukai ele mergulha no campo
emergente da Medicina no hidrogênio
molecular esse livro é muito
interessante eu recomendo vocês que
gostam de estudar que não tem medo de
linguagem um pouco mais científica
Apesar que esse livro é bastante
acessível ele é um testemunho do
potencial do hidrogênio molecular na
Esfera médica esse Y fukai é um
professor emérito da Universidade chu em
Tokio no Japão ele tem extensa
experiência em física química e ciênci
doos materiais então é um sujeito
realmente um crânio que estuda várias
áreas diferentes ele fornece um guia
abrangente sobre os efeitos terapêuticos
e possíveis aplicações que nós vamos
falar também ao longo dessa Live as
aplicações médicas do hidrogênio
molecular mas antes de eu continuar aqui
eu queria que o Marcelo Nonato se
apresentasse para vocês e Contasse a
história pessoal dele muito tocante que
levou ele a estudar profundamente o
hidrogênio levou a ele ele onde o
professor pardal e construiu uma máquina
ele vai contar a história para vocês e
aí ele aprofundou os seus estudos e hoje
O Marcelo é uma referência nessa área
muito boa noite
Marcelo boa noite dout laim Boa noite a
todos que nos acompanham como o doutor
disse né o hidrogênio é a menor molécula
que existe na aí no planeta só que é a
maior em poder de antioxidante Eu
costumo falar que Deus colocou na Menor
das matéri da das moléculas o maior
poder antioxidante né é um bombeiro que
apaga o incêndio que é a inflamação e
com excelência sem deixar nenhum tipo de
efeito colateral mas eu vou vou me
apresentar já me apresentei Meu nome é
Marcelo Nonato há 3 anos atrás eu não
sabia o que era hidrogênio e minha mãe
ela sofria muito ela tinha muitas dores
de Artrite artrose reumatoide os dedos
da mão dela já estava inchando para
atrofiar e aquilo magoava muito a gente
visitar ela e de manhã até de noite ela
desejar a própria morte por conta das
Dores ela preferia eh Deixar de Viver do
que continuar vivendo com tantas dores e
aí cansado de ver ela sofrer eu fui
pesquisar na internet alguma coisa para
trazer uma solução para ela então eu
pensei que eu ia achar uma raiz uma
folha para fazer um chá para amenizar as
dores só que o que que apareceu para mim
um artigo científico falando que o
hidrogênio molecular conseguia dar
alívio para todas as dores que ela
sentia E aí eu pensei tá fácil só que
esse tá fácil era eu acho alguma coisa
que produz hidrogênio e eu saro a minha
mãe porém a as máquinas elas eram muito
caras eu estava desempregado era época
de pandemia E aí eu lembrei da minha
infância que eu gostava de desmontar
tudo em casa e aí eu pensei eu não posso
comprar meu equipamento mas isso eu
produzi o meu próprio E é claro que tem
muitas coisas que podem contaminar o
hidrogênio então eu estudei por seis
meses para poder montar o primeiro
equipamento tudo que eu poderia usar que
viesse ajudar minha mãe e entre erros e
acertos eh tive que ter muita paciência
porque você fazer com que a menor
molécula saia no lugar certo é é é quase
que impossível Então tinha que ter muita
paciência para construir esse
equipamento e quando o primeiro ficou
pronto eu falei assim eu não vou levar
para ela agora eu vou testar em mim aí
se eu morrer eu levo para ela né vamos
ver E aí eu comecei tomar água e eu era
um cara que eu não tinha nenhuma
patologia aos meus olhos só que eu tinha
uma que muita gente não sabe eu tinha um
cansaço e e a fadiga sabe eu chegava em
casa seim eu queria ficar sentado no
sofá eu não queria descer para brincar
com a minha filha então eu era muito
fadigado cansaço estafa e depois que eu
comecei a tomar essa água eu comecei a
ter muita dispos eu que pegava minha
filha para brincar e a minha esposa
vendo isso falou Nossa você tá mais
elétrico com mais disposição aí eu
pensei Deixa eu estudar artigo
científico e ao estudar os artigos eu
descobri que o cansaço é uma doença
mitocondrial e que a mitocôndria por ser
o motor da célula ela é responsável por
dar a disposição que a gente tem energia
e aí eu falei funciona porque eu tô aqui
com toda a energia todo o vapor vou
levar pra minha mãe aí eu levei Doutor
pessoal que tá nos assistindo três dias
ela entrou em contato com a minha esposa
por telefone perguntando o que era
aquilo que ela podia bater po chinelo
que ela não sentia mais dores a tristeza
foi embora as dores foram embora e eu
pensei ela deve est tomando remédio
junto Falei pra minha esposa Pergunta se
ela tá tomando algum medicamento porque
é surreal três dias aí a minha esposa
perguntou Você tá tomando alguma coisa
junto ela não só tô tomando a água aí eu
falei funciona
E aí depois desse dia eu entendi o o que
o hidrogênio faz na vida das pessoas
porque eu não deixei de estudar artigos
científicos e a cada dia que passa eu me
intero mais do assunto então hoje eh Às
vezes a gente tá numa roda de de médicos
eu não sou médico eu não sou formado mas
por conta de querer ajudar minha mãe eu
comecei a me aprofundar tanto na
medicina integrativa que as pessoas
perguntam Qual que é a minha formação
pergunta se eu sou médico eu falo não eu
sou só o rapaz que queria salvar a mãe e
isso me impulsionou a estudar acho que
todo mundo que entra na medicina tem
alguma história que impulsionou ele
entrar ali ou na medicina integrativa ou
na medicina tradicional e e é algo que
mudou a minha vida a vida da minha mãe e
a vida de muita gente no Brasil e no
mundo inteiro que que já é adepto a essa
medicina muito bem introdução excelente
aí do Marcelo então Marcelo é um tipo de
pessoa que eu admiro porque ele tem um
problema ele não ficou passivo ele não
ficou esperando o governo resolver não
ficou esperando cair do céu não ficou
numa atitude passiva né de coitadismo né
eu falo coitadismo mas você sabe que é
vitimismo coitadismo sbe que é mais
engraçado né A palavra correta é
vitimismo não ficou nessa posição e foi
e foi atrás Conseguiu resolver construiu
equipamento estudou o assunto hoje ele é
uma das referências aí na parte de como
lidar com esses equipamentos então daqui
a pouco ele vai mostrar para vocês aí
uma série de equipamentos que usa essa
tecnologia do hidrogênio e também falar
mais a respeito mas eu vou continuar na
minha exposição aqui tem umas perguntas
aqui já estão um pouquinho avançadas no
tema O Eliseu perguntou do rp daqui a
pouco a gente vai falar de RP explicar o
que que é isso né a gente vai responder
a pergunta do Eliseu né o Rubens tá
comentando que que a garrafa realmente
hidrogena água eu não sei se é uma
pergunta ou uma afirmação né vamos
entender que isso seja uma pergunta
hidrogena assim Rubens até que fica uma
pressão dentro da garrafa quando você
abre Sai até uma fumacinha viu Eh
realmente não é cascata não certo eu tô
tô aqui com uma garrafinha aqui ó então
eu posso garantir para vocês tomam essa
água hidrogenada todos os dias
eh que realmente isso funciona a
tá agradecendo obrigado Eliana aqui pela
seu depoimento grande abraço para você
boa noite eice João né E tem aqui acho
que essa pergunta aqui já é interessante
talvez a gente responder né qual seria o
segredo do hidrogênio gás ou elétron
então eh a gente tá falando aqui do
hidrogênio molecular tá que é diferente
do íon hidrogênio né da da molécula
hidroxila então tem as moléculas
pode até ter a mesma
conformação molecular Mas dependendo de
como tá organizado ela tem propriedades
diferentes tá então a gente tá falando
aqui do hidrogênio molecular e a
descoberta científica sobre o hidrogênio
começa em 2007 né Isso foi relatado
naquele livro que eu comentei agora no
começo da Live então em 2007 foi
descoberto que a inalação de gás
hidrogênio reduz as espécies reativas de
oxigênio ou seja tem efeito antioxidante
e a essas espécies ativas de oxigênio
são altamente prejudiciais esse primeiro
estudo foi feito em ratos essa
descoberta inicial de 2007 abru caminho
para mais pesquisas veja que um assunto
é recente 2007 é pouco tempo para
começar um estudo né e então começou
mais pesquisas mais ensaios clínicos que
apresentaram resultados promissores eem
uma multiplicidade de condições de saúde
então o trabalho do fucai aquele autor
do livro que eu comentei é
particularmente muito significativo
porque ele compila apresenta essas
descobertas E também o Marcelo vai
contar pra gente outros depoimentos que
ele ficou sabendo de pessoas que foram
beneficiados por hidrogênio daqui a
pouco ele vai contar para
vocês então o livro apresenta essas
descobertas tanto pra comunidade
científica para também os leigos o
público em comum porque a maioria das
pessoas Inclusive a maioria dos médicos
hoje não conhecem ainda o hidrogênio
estão desinformados sobre o potencial
médico certo
Então as evidências pode falar pode
falar Marcelo é nessa pergunta aí por
exemplo quando o a parte positiva ali da
eletrólise e tem o anodo e o catodo aí o
Polo positivo ele produz oxigênio O
negativo ele produz o hidrogênio então o
Polo positivo ele tá doando um elétron
pro hidrogênio então ele carrega esse
eletronegativo E aí um exemplo eh todos
os nossos radicais livres formados pelo
oxigênio eles são viciados em elétrons
negativos e as nossas células cada
célula tem um elétron negativo Então
esse Radical Livre em excesso quando o
corpo tá so estess oxidativo ele perde a
capacidade de neutralizar esse excesso
de radicais livres então o Radical Livre
que é viciado em elétron negativo ele
vai roubar da célula e essa célula
começa a oxidar que gruda em outra que
gruda em outra que tem elétron para
tentar sobreviver gruda na outra que tem
elétron e quando a pessoa toma essa água
com o hidrogênio ou inalo o gás o que
que acontece o hidrogênio carrega esse
elétron e ele devolve pra célula
danificada a célula volta a ser jovem e
os radicais livres em excesso ele também
dou elétron para eles para que eles não
eh roubem mais elétron da célula então
aí ele consegue fazer esse equilíbrio
então tem esse esse segredinho aí do do
elétron que Ele carrega também perfeito
bem explicado Isso aí até de uma forma
simples simples né então o hidrogênio
ele é muito importante né o próprio
Marcelo comentou da mãe dele que tinha
fortes dores e o hidrogênio aliviou as
dores ele tem potencial antiinflamatório
antioxidante vai melhorar vários
disturbios metabólicos vai dar síndrome
metabólica inflamação até as doenças
neurodegenerativas como é o caso do
Alzheimer e paxo Inclusive tem um
paciente meu recente que comprou pra
esposa que tem a doença de alzheimer o
hidrogênio molecular para inalar né
então estudos T demonstrado que o
hidrogênio molecular ele atua como
antioxidante seletivo ou seja ele vai
onde ele é preciso ele não vai fazer uma
antioxidação sem critério porque a gente
precisa de um pouco de estress oxidativo
nas células por as células de defesa
Nossa utilizam o o as espécies ativas de
oxigênio para matar bactérias matar
vírus então a gente usa também o stress
oxidativo por nosso favor Então nem todo
o stress oxidativo é ruim certo então o
hidrogênio é seletivo ele vai onde ele é
preciso e vai neutralizar radicais lives
como o radical hidroxila op
peroxinitrito eles são altamente
reativos e podem causar danos
significativos à parede das a parede das
células também danos ao nosso DNA e ao
mesmo tempo o hidrogênio não interfere
com os radicais livres que desempenham
papéis importantes no nosso organismo
como é o caso do sistema imune como eu
acab de falar e a sinalização também
celular Então essa seletividade é uma
das grandes vantagens é uma das grandes
razões pelas quais o hidrogênio
molecular é considerado o antioxidante
promissor antioxidante promissor porque
se você tomou um
antioxidante muito bom que não é
seletivo Às vezes você pode estar
prejudicando Essas funções importantes
do organismo então é importante nós
protegermos o organismo sem perturbar
esse equilíbrio oxidativo porque
antigamente quando eu comecei a estar
otom moleculara eh se falava
antioxidação antioxidação e hoje a gente
entende que tem que ter um equilíbrio
não é antioxid tudo nem oxidar tudo tem
que ter um equilíbrio a gente tem que na
verdade combater o excesso de stresse
oxidativo então além D propriedades
antioxidantes o hidrogênio tem efeitos
antiinflamatórios por isso que a mãe do
Marcelo melhorou da dor por que que
acontece isso porque o hidrogênio
contribui para a modulação desses
processos inflamatórios
isso é muito importante porque a
inflamação crônica tá ligada a
praticamente todas as doenças que levam
à morte na maioria das pessoas as mortes
por doenças crônicas Então tá tá ligado
a osteoartrite a câncer a diabetes
problemas de coração AVC então é é 70%
das mortes praticamente tem alguma coisa
a ver com inflamação crônica Inclusive
tem ação contra asma e Artrite
reumatoide isso porque o hidrogênio tem
a capacidade de influenciar de maneira
positiva né nossa saúde
eh interferindo na sinalização das
moléculas inflamatórias né na Cascata
inflamatória inibindo esse excesso de
inflamação e por isso tem um amplo
espectro de aplicações terapêuticas que
justifica o crescente
interesse na pesquisa e desenvolvimento
né então a importância do hidrogênio
para vida é inegável a sua presença é
essencial nos processos biológicos a
ligação do hidrogênio por exemplo é
muito importante crucial paraa estrutura
e função de moléculas biológicas o DNA
por exemplo as proteínas o hidrogênio
também é um componente chave na produção
de energia da molécula de energia ATP
que é a principal molécula de
armazenamento de energia na células e
com a evolução da pesquisa o hidrogênio
molecular está sendo reconhecido não
apenas como componente Vital da
bioquímica Mas também como agente
terapêutico um grande potencial de
impactar a saúde humana mas vamos ver
vamos responder mais alguma pergunta
aqui e vou falar de o RP Então tá já que
tem essa pergunta do Eliseu fala para
nós o que que é o RP
Marcelo toda a água do mundo ela é
oxidante ela precisa ser oxidante porque
até ela sair do saneamento básico que
realmente é básico é o básico do básico
até ela chegar na casa da pessoa existem
tantos canos quebrados esgoto clori
Formes fecais a água chega um caos na
casa da pessoa então ela tem que ser
oxidante porque eh se ela sair da do
saneamento básico
antioxidante ela vai aderir ali várias
bactérias ninguém ia sobreviver todo
mundo ia passar mal então ela tem que
ser oxidante Porém quando ela chega na
torneira da pessoa a pessoa tem que ter
um bom filtro para tirar resíduos tem
que ter eh nanopartículas de prata
carvão ativado a prata ela é um
antibactericida que mata bactéria
só que nenhum filtro tem a capacidade de
deixar a água muito antioxidante ele
consegue abaixar um pouco o RP só que
não deixar muito negativa e o que que
acontece é toda a água precisa ser
oxidante aí a pessoa fala não mas eu
tomo uma água mineral quanto mais tempo
a garrafinha a água tiver
engarrafada mais oxidante Ela vai ficar
aí eu vou usar como exemplo a criança
acabou de nascer o bebê nasceu a mãe tá
amamentando as crianças que são
amamentadas elas tendem elas tendem a
ter menos doenças ao longo da vida o
leite materno é antioxidante o RP do
leite é
-70 a mulher quando vai fazer o detox
que ela vai tomar aquele chá verde para
ter a pele bonita desintoxicar as
células Por que que o chá verde funciona
ele é um antioxidante o RP -1 a água
hidrogenada o RP -600
quando ela tá muito
saturada garganta secou Desculpa então o
que que acontece a pessoa ela
tomou uma água oxidante não vai est
mudando nada e se ela tiver um pH baixo
não vai tá
hidratando perdão não vai est hidratando
100%
o que que muda com RP quando o
hidrogênio na eletrólise quebra a a
molécula ali da água e transforma no gás
Ele carrega um eletronegativo esse
eletronegativo ele vai deixar a água que
era oxidante um
antioxidante Gente desculpa eu engasguei
aqui tá precisando de água hidrogenada
tomar mais aí é quando eu eu falei aí
deu uma
então quando a pessoa toma a água
antioxidante ela tá repondo elétrons ela
tá sendo hidratada seis vezes mais e E
aí por isso que a água é oxidante Só que
lá em okin no Japão tem uma Nascente que
libera através dos minerais que tem
naquela Nascente libera hidrogênio na
água e aí essa água ela é
antioxidante e o povo lá vive mais de
100 anos então o que que a gente entende
se a pessoa elá Tom explique pro pessoal
o conceito do rp porque você falou RP
negativo eh fala a diferença fala a
diferença no RP positivo com RP negativo
o RP positivo ele oxida ele é oxidante e
o RP negativo quanto mais negativo mais
antioxidante é pronto esse essencial é
porque o ele vai contar a história de
oknal aí mas antes de de contar eh essa
história do RP tá essa é água oxida ou
se tá eu não vou entrar aqui em detalhes
da química porque vocês podem se
confundir Mas é uma questão de doação de
elétron tá quem doa elétron certo
geralmente é oxidante quem recebe é um
agente redutor Então esse menos tanto aí
acho que o Eliseu quis dizer menos 400
acho não não sei o que el quis dizer na
verdade mas pode ser que ele tá falando
de 400 positivo e realmente uma água tem
o 400 positivo é oxidante se fosse Men
400 seria antioxidante pode continuar
por favor ó um refrigerante aquele
conhecido que todo mundo gosta o RP é
mais
600 super oxidante tanto é que paraa
neutralização dele a pessoa tem que
tomar depois 32 copos
d'água se a pessoa tomar uma água
antioxidante com rp-6 água já neutraliza
aquela ação oxidante do
refrigerante então só para você ver o
potencial que o hidrogênio tem de eh ser
um antioxidante muito
poderoso pode falar a história do kinal
você falar que a água quinal é anti tá
então lá tem Minerais Magnésio turmalina
negra infravermelho eh prata
marítima nessa nascente e a água
diferente de todo o lugar do mundo lá já
nasce
antioxidante Então as pessoas já nascem
tomando essa água e elas e envelhecem e
morrem da forma mais digna que existe
que é de causas naturais acima de 100
anos sem doença sem dor isso que é o
fantástico eles só tomam água
antioxidante e a dieta deles é rica em
antioxidantes sim uma série de fatores a
ilha dein é uma das blones zonas azuis
do mundo tem essa questão que ele falou
aí da água antioxidante tem a questão da
alimentação de okin que é parecido com
com a alimentação mediterrânea tem a
questão de comunidade que é uma
comunidade que se ajuda mutuamente os
idosos não são abandonados tem um
espírito de corpo forte lá de
comunidades também influencia mas
certamente a água antioxidante é
um primordiais Mas pode continuar e e
tem algumas coisas aqui tem alguns itens
que eles fazem a água da pessoa ficar
exatamente igual por exemplo hoje o
idoso ele ele tem
osteoporose porque o Brasil tem
deficiência em magnésio então a pessoa
que tem deficiência em magnésio o corpo
por não tem magnésio não consegue
absorver o cálcio Então vai
enfraquecendo os ossos uma água que ela
tem pequenas doses de magnésio a pessoa
que absorve que toma essa água qualquer
nutriente qualquer alimento que tenha
cálcio o corpo vai absorver dificilmente
ela vai ter uma osteoporose na terceira
idade eu vou pedir uma aqui rapidinho eu
vou pegar um uma pastilha que ela imita
aquela água de okin aí eu vou mostrar
para vocês só um
minutinho enquanto ele vai lá pegar a
pastilha então nós sabemos hoje que tem
vários estudos comprovando os benefícios
do hidrogênio molecular então esses
estudos T demonstrado essa série de
benefícios paraa saúde entre as suas
propriedades mais notáveis está a
questão antioxidante que eu já falei
né E também a questão
antiinflamatória estudos indicam que o
hidrogênio pode suprimir a ativação das
vias inflamatórias no corpo uma delas é
a a via nfk Beta e reduzir a produção de
mediadores inflamatórios como é o caso
do fator de necrose tumoral alfa e o
óxido nítrico em excesso que atua também
como agente oxidante Então essa ação
antiinflamatória é muito benéfica para
eh condições de inflamação crônica como
asma doenças cardiovasculares oferecendo
então uma abordagem muito interessante e
nova pro tratamento melhoria de
qualidade de vida do pacient com
praticamente zero efeito colateral
mostra pra gente aí a pastilha Marcelo é
é fazendo adendo aí
eh apari um artigo científico falando
que antioxidantes em excesso pode elevar
a ao nível do risco da pessoa ter câncer
mas é o é o antioxidante convencional
por conta dele neutralizar todos os
radicais livres já o hidrogênio só
neutraliza os dois que são os que fazem
mal então por isso ele bem seletivo essa
aqui pessoal é a
pastilha essa pastilha aqui quando você
põe na água ela libera até eh o RP se
você colocar num Squeeze de até 400 ml
ela vai chegar aí a -700 o RP e umas
1000 100 partículas por bilhão de
hidrogênio na água vai liberar prata
marítima eh infravermelho longo para
ionizar a água então hoje a gente tem
várias formas de produzir hidrogênio na
água por exemplo a garrafinha ela é uma
das maneiras mais potentes de deixar a
água saturada ao grau máximo por quê
Porque o RP vai chegar a
-600 e as partículas por bilhão até 5000
partículas por bilhão de hidrogênio na á
água e aí doutor tem um detalhe que as
pessoas não sabem eh não é qualquer
garrafa porque tem a garrafa que tem a
tecnologia legítima e tem a garrafa que
não tem e a diferença é a que não tem
ela vai liberar metal pesado na água ela
não vai ter o descarte de oxigênio no
fundo que tem que ter o descarte de
oxigênio que é esse furinho
aqui porque a água mineral a água de
torneira filtrada ela tem minerais sódio
cloro fluor e se você fizer eletrólise
com a tecnologia que não é legítima vai
fabricar Gá cloro CO2 gás cloro é uma
arma química então a importância da
pessoa pesquisar o titânio legítimo que
é o a matériaprima para produzir as
garrafas eles são mais caro que o ouro
então Eh quando vocês vê garrafa de 200
500 R 700 dificilmente vai ter uma
tecnologia legítima lá e toda garrafinha
ela tem que ter o descarte de oxigênio
Para não misturar o gás oxigênio na água
aqui em cima só vai o hidrogênio puro o
oxigênio com os outros gases saem aqui
então tem que tomar cuidado na hora de
escolher a
garrafinha muito bom então tem uma
pergunta aqui complementar né Eh a
pergunta é quanto mais negativo o RP
melhor água o que que você diz pra
gente Sim quanto menor o RP quanto mais
negativo melhor menos do 200 eu entendo
assim pessoal ó se você tomar uma água a
men 600 1,5 dessa água equivale ao poder
antioxidante que o consumo de mais de
700 bananas ou mais de 500 maçãs ou mais
de 38 cenouras isso você teria que comer
para ter a mesma ação de antioxidantes
no seu organismo agora eh por exemplo se
você tomar uma água menos 200 é 1000
vezes melhor você tomar água menos 200
do que você tomar uma água positiva mais
350 mais 400 tem lugar em São Paulo um
exemplo em Osasco um rapaz mediu o RP da
água da torneira dele tava mais 600 era
um refrigerante a água do cara então a
importância de ter um bom filtro para
pelo menos limpar a água chega pesada a
pessoa toma água não sente é saciada e
ainda sente aquele peso na barriga
água hidrogenada a água é leve e outro
mito outra mentira que o pessoal fala
por aí é que a água hidrogenada aumenta
o PH da água é mentira pessoal o PH da
água é só pode aumentar através de
minerais minerais aumenta o PH da água o
hidrogênio é uma partícula neutra
partícula neutra não tem poder de an e
de elevar o PH da água então o PH vai
manter o mesmo então se você colocar por
exemplo água da garrafinha se você você
colocar uma água com pH alto no final da
hidrogenização da água o PH vai tá igual
só que o RP vai est negativo E assim a
gente não consegue achar nenhum artigo
científico que fala que o pH alto traz
algum benefício porém e de hidrogênio
molecular de orp de água saturada de
hidrogênio já existem mais de
480.000 artigos aí você pode achar esses
artigos na
pubmed pode achar
na na no Google academic lá são os
lugares certos para você pesquisar
artigos sobre
hidrogênio
perfeito vamos ver se nós temos mais
perguntas
aqui Juan muito obrigado pelo seu
carinho de sempre
ah essa pergunta aqui a condutividade da
água melhora com RP negativo que que
você diz para noss sim é o prau a
condutibilidade só que é claro que
quanto melhor a qualidade da sua água
melhor o hidrogênio vai fixar entre os
espaços da molécula de H2 ou seja se
você tem uma água suja uma água pesada o
hidrogênio não vai ter espaço para fixar
porque já tá saturada de outras coisas
então se você tiver um filtro bom quando
você levar o hidrogênio para essa água
essa água vai est mais leve Então vai
melhorar a condutibilidade vai aumentar
o poder de óxido redutor que é o
potencial redox que é o orp então ela
vai ficar mais negativa então quanto
melhor a qualidade melhor a o hidrogênio
vai negativar e vai melhorar a qualidade
dela em todos os aspectos olha seria
interessante você explicar não sei se
você já estudou essa parte da química e
da física também fique à vontade para eh
dizer que talvez não tenha essa
informação Mas explica para nós por
exemplo Gente o que que é uma água ácida
que tem muitos Íons de hidrogênio certo
PH é ácido porque tem muitos Íons de
hidrogênio mas o íon de hidrogênio é
diferente do hidrogênio molecular então
explica para nós como é que a água fica
hidrogenada sem ela fic
ácida então ó é por conta desse desse
elétron se eu pegar uma água ácida e eu
hidrogenar ela ela vai ficar com RP
negativo porém ela vai ficar com ph
ácido ela é ácida o hidrogênio não vai
conseguir deixar aumentar o PH agora se
eu colocar Bic um pouco de bicarbonato
de só
Se eu colocar um pouco de magnésio isso
já muda a história da água a água vai
começar a ficar e com ph mais alto eu
não consigo e deixar essa água com pH
alto apenas com
hidrogênio Tá mas é porque existe uma
diferença o o do hidrogênio ele vai
acidificar n o PH medida de quantos I de
hidrogênio estão dissolvidos no meio né
isso isso e e o hidrog hiio molecular
não é a mesma coisa que o de hidrogênio
é por isso que o pessoal confunde não eh
e acha que porque a água tá hidrogenada
ela tá ácida não é não é a o ato de
hidrogenar a água não vai tornar ela
mais áci é a mesma coisa tipo quando
fala peróxido de hidrogênio quando fala
gordura eh hidrogenada eh então é é tudo
por exemplo é H3 não é H2 é outro tipo
de hidrogênio e o hidrogênio ele ele só
tem esse poder do elétron de abaixar o
RP por conta da eletrólise que ele pegou
um elétron positivo ou Por conta desses
minerais que ele vai fazer esse o o
hidrogênio molecular são duas moléculas
de hidrogênio juntas é o H2 Sim Isso é o
H2 enquanto que o o íon h+ que é o íon
de hidrogênio é um hidrogênio sozinho tá
exato Então essa que é a diferença então
Eh pelo fato de você tá hidrogen a
água ela não vai est mais ácida porque
esse hidrogênio que tá entrando nela é
um hidrogênio molecular não é o
hidrogênio na forma de íon de hidrogênio
né isso que pode confundir a cabeça de
muitas pessoas eh que é uma
particularidade aí da da química né a
pergunta aí que que você pode responder
pro
Eliseu olha Eh o que que a gente tem
notado de TRS anos para cá eh eu não sei
para aqui não serve serve para tudo por
exemplo ó cansaço físico e mental a
pessoa ela não trabalha com peso mas ela
trabalha com a cabeça esse cansaço
físico e mental quando a pessoa ela
inala uma hora de hidrogênio ela tem uma
uma noite de sono reparadora ela tem
mais disposição para eh tarefas do dia a
dia à noite se eh existem pessoas que
elas começam a ter mais disposição elas
ficam mais elétricas e não conseguem
dormir porque o corpo tava tão
debilitado que quando ele Ele carrega
com essa energia que o hidrogênio
oferece e a pessoa passa a ter
disposição O que o corpo não fazia antes
por falta de disposição começa a ter e a
pessoa nem dorme existem pessoas que já
dormem melhor e existem pessoas que
ficam elétricas para essas pessoas a
gente recomenda inalar durante o dia
agora depois de um dia cansado quem é
saudável não precisa inalar todo dia a
água sim pode tomar todo dia mas a
inalação para quem é saudável pode ser
um dia sim um dia não uma vez na semana
aquele dia que você tá mais estressado
eh não foi um dia legal no serviço teve
que trabalhar muito com a mente então
esses dias assim PR as pessoas saudáveis
a gente recomenda o hidrogênio ajuda sim
eh tinha uma outra pergunta aqui que eu
não sei se estava mais para trás ou para
frente mas eu acho que você pode estar
respondendo que que você acha do hidrog
V molecular para atividade física para
quem gosta de fazer musculação ou fazer
aeróbico prova de resistência prova de
por exemplo corridas longas por aí vai
quando eu comecei tomar antes de levar o
aparelho pra minha mãe e eu tive muita
disposição eu fui direto nos artigos
científicos lá eu achei artigo
científico que fala do hidrogênio para
na área do esporte atletas de alta
performance tiveram as suas lesões
curadas mais rápido do que eh se não
fosse com hidrogênio e tava lá o artigo
científico falando que aumentava eh o
nível do Atleta por exemplo deixava o
atleta mais
competitivo por conta de diminuir as
dores aumenta a massa muscular e diminui
peso ou seja para quem é atleta tem um
jogador famoso eu não vou citar o nome
dele que no ano que ele ia se aposentar
ele começou a tomar água hidrogenada de
um aparelho aí E aí o que que aconteceu
aquele ano ele ganhou o título de melhor
jogador de futebol do mundo e ele ia se
aposentar aquele ano então pra área do
Esporte e dá um um Pub média aí um
Google academic e coloca lá hidrogen
esports tem que escrever em inglês as eu
falei muita coisa na Live anterior na
Live anterior tava falando sozinho né
não tinha participação do Marcelo então
eu decidi nessa Live dar mais ênfase as
perguntas que já estão S várias aqui se
por acaso ficar uma lacuna de perguntas
alguém não tiver uma pergunta muito
relevante para fazer a gente volta mais
na parte teórica Tá mas eu falei desse
assunto do hidrogênio no esporte na Live
anterior assim como eu falei de várias
outras condições tá então depois de
assistir essa Live vai na Live anterior
que foi no mês de fevereiro Procura lá
no canal ou então escreve no na na
barrinha de de busca do YouTube meu nome
lá em Dutra hidrogênio você vai achar a
Live anterior que eu foquei bastante na
teoria mas a gente vai repetir vários
conceitos aqui só tô avisando que a
gente pode ser que não fale alguma coisa
ou tá dando mais enfoque aqui as
perguntas né
Ah aqui você já comentou eu acho que
talvez a pessoa não sei se ela ouviu eh
como separar o hidrogênio do oxigênio
você já falou que esse aparelhinho essa
garrafinha tem um escape de oxigênio
certo aqui embaixo isso c tem uma
membrana separadora de prótons quando a
a eletrólise é feita no mesmo ambiente
que a a pessoa vai tomar água ela tem
que ter por lei essa membrana para não
deixar os gases se misturar porque aqui
é o ambiente que a pessoa vai tomar água
se o Polo positivo e O negativo tivesse
aqui em cima o positivo quando ele doa
há um desgaste e esse desgaste ia ficar
na água a pessoa ia tomar uma água que
ia fazer mal com metais pesados CO2 eh
gás cloro Então tem que ter só a parte
negativa em cima membrana é é titânio e
e o Segredo dessa é que ela também tem
titânio embaixo na parte positiva então
o desgaste por a dureza do titânio ser
muito eh firme é difícil desgaste então
jamais por conta da membrana ela vai
contaminar água ela vai reter só vai ter
a parte negativa a parte negativa na
eletrólise pessoal ela nunca vai
desgastar nem se fosse Vai um prego um
prego que eu achei na rua Se eu colocar
ele como negativo ele vai ficar intacto
para sempre ele não desgasta agora o o
Polo positivo desgasta porque é ele que
tá doando ali o elétron pro polo
negativo então o segredo da garrafinha
ela tem que ter o titânio legítimo a
membrana só que ela tem que separar
esses polos em cima só negativo no meio
a membrana embaixo o Polo Positivo já
nos aparelhos por exemplo eu vou mostrar
um aparelho aqui
ó esse aparelho aqui
ele produz hidrogênio e oxigênio aí aqui
eu tenho duas saídas eu tenho saída de
hidrogênio e saída de oxigênio aí esse
aparelho aqui
ele diferente da garrafinha ele quebra a
molécula lá dentro então ele tá
quebrando a molécula dentro dele e
dentro dele sai só o gás aí esse gás eu
posso colocar esse acessório aqui ó e eu
vou levar hidrogênio para minha água aí
eu tô hidrogen minha água num copo só
que aí eu não vou hidrogenar água agora
agora eu quero levar hidrogênio para os
olhos aí eu vou conectar o óculos então
o aparelho ele serve para várias funções
por exemplo aí a pessoa fala ah mas por
que que eu vou levar hidrogênio pro
óculos os artigos científicos falam só
que a gente além dos artigos científicos
a gente tá vendo coisas eh melhores que
os artigos científicos a gente vê a
pessoa que i a operar de catarata não
precisar operar por conta do hidrogênio
glaucoma degeneração macular síndrome do
olho seco todas essas doenças causadas
por oxidação
degenerativas elas através do óculos o
hidrogênio tá conseguindo reverter essa
situação aí eu não quero usar o óculos
eu tenho zumbido de ouvido eu tenho
hostiles inflamações nos ossos do
tímpano o que que eu vou fazer eu vou
colocar o fone eu vou levar esse gás
provido aí Ah agora eu vou inalar aí o
que que eu faço eu coloco esse cateter
tipo óculos no aparelho e eu vou inalar
inalar por uma hora por exemplo se eu
sou saudável naqueles dias mais cansados
eu vou ver a a a melhora na hora agora
Se eu não sou saudável só tô muito eh
debilitado quer dizer se eu sou saudável
eu não vou eu não vou perceber muito
agora se eu se eu tiver muito cansado
sim agora a pessoa que tá muito
debilitada ela tá camada e ela tá sob
estress oxidativo ela tá um caus ali o
terreno biológico da pessoa se ela
inalar por uma hora na na mesma hora ela
já vai sentir a diferença porque ela ela
recebeu um bombardeio de energia num
corpo que tava debilitado e outra forma
também de saber a funcionabilidade do
hidrogênio assim de imediato uma hora
inalando é através da microscopia de
Campo escuro a pessoa ela faz uma
microscopia antes e uma microscopia
depois que inal o hidrogênio aí eu vou
mostrar para vocês aqui ó uma
microscopia de Campo
escuro aqui ó olha lá em cima ó as
hemácias aglomeradas e uma hora depois
de hidrogênio aqui embaixo ó as células
perfeitas
eh desaglomerar por qu aqui elas estavam
sem elétrons aqui ainda tá boa a pessoa
não tava muito sob muito estress mas tem
microscopia que isso daqui tá tudo
grudado uma na outra você nem enxerga as
bolinhas porque é uma emass estava
atraindo a outra estavam se atraindo as
cargas na na parede das emass quando
você agora aqui melhora aí o estress
oxidativo as cargas negativas da parede
da da emassa se reconstitui e as emass
se repelem como se fosse ímas certo aí
agora olha que fator interessante nossa
células nosso DNA eles estão sempre se
replicando é xerox da Xerox da Xerox
agora se você tem uma célula um monte de
célula você tá so stress oxidativo tudo
danificada tudo oxidada na replicação o
que que vai acontecer imagina pegar uma
célula ruim replicar para outra ruim que
replica pra outra a xerox da Xerox vai
chegar uma hora que não vai tá legal
aquilo ali só vai cair em decadência
agora se você por exemplo faz a inalação
do hidrogênio sua célula Tá nov
renovou as células na hora da replicação
ela vai replicar a célula nova da célula
nova da célula nova então é por isso é
que ele tem um poder gigante ele ele por
ser pequeno ele consegue chegar ali
ultrapassar a membrana celular já as
outras maneiras de de antioxidante já
não conseguem ter essa
eficiência uma pergunta aqui você falou
que pode usar o hidrogênio aí no no fone
né
assim ajudar a prevenir surdez
dependendo do tipo né Qual que é a causa
dessa surdez agora reverter surdez
acredito que não Você conhece algum
relato de alguém que reverteu ó se o
timpa não tiver furado não tem como
agora já aconteceu de uma senhora falar
comigo tipo a gente estuda hidrogênio a
gente tem um grupo e que ela para falar
com os parentes ela tinha que deixar no
viva voz e ficava pedindo pra pessoa
repetir aí e ela relatou que depois que
ela começou a usar hidrogênio nos
ouvidos através do fone ela não usa mais
o viva voz e ela não pede pra pessoa
repetir mais nesse caso foi alguma coisa
ali causada por oxidação o hidrogênio
por ser um perfeito antioxidante
conseguiu reverter mas não é todo caso e
às vezes eu falo tipo para as pessoas eh
olha a minha mãe teve um benefício em
três dias eu conheço várias pessoas que
tiveram benefícios em quro dias em uma
semana só que cada organismo reage de
uma maneira diferente
não significa que todo mundo vai ficar
bom em TR dias porque é cada organismo
reage de uma maneira diferente com
certeza Exatamente isso obrigado pelo
comentário viu Valdemar Então você
descobriu mais uma ferramenta aí pr dor
crônica né não só os fitoterápicos que
também gosto muito a Jandira com várias
dores de quadril achei uma boa jir
experimentar o hidrogênio né
Marcelo sim vai ajudar no vai ajudar nos
alívios das Dores e o Eliseu né pergunta
da aparência da pele ele quer ficar
bonitão como que deixa eu ver se tá aqui
ó ó a vergonha nacional que eu vou
passar aqui
ó gente eu antes do
hidrogênio aqui
não não dá para ver direito não vai dar
ó eu tenho eu vou fazer 44 anos anos eu
não tenho rugas eu não tenho e existem
artigos científicos que falam que ele é
por ser antioxidante aí já já diz tudo
mas ele consegue fazer o corpo produzir
colágeno ele por renovar célula ele
retarda o envelhecimento e faz o corpo
produzir colágeno então ah não precisa
falar mais nada teve uma mulher que
falou que ela era louca do hidrogênio
por ela pegava água hidrogenada até para
lavar os cabelos e aí ela ela falou que
hidratou melhor do que com os
hidratantes dela e tem artigo científico
que fala que o hidrogênio pro pra cabeça
ali para lavar o o couro cabeludo ajuda
na foliculite e na
seborreia legal
hein sofro de depressão agora tenho
falta de energia então com certeza vai
te ajudar Obviamente você não vai ser
curada da depressão acredito que não a
não ser que a sua depressão seja
totalmente
inflamatória e mas com certeza vai
melhorar e vai melhorar sua falta de
energia pode falar Doutor no nosso grupo
a gente recebeu vários relatos de
pessoas com depressão o que que acontece
a disbiose intestinal a gente tem notado
através de várias microscopias de Campo
escuro que quase todo mundo tá com
disbiose e a disbiose ela desencadeia
para várias doenças como artrite artrose
inclusive depressão nós já recebemos
vários del
latos de pessoas que elas até tipo eh
quando a pessoa toma um remédio
controlado ela às vezes tem que fazer o
às vezes não sempre ela tem que fazer o
desmame né Nós recebemos depoimentos de
pessoas que não precisaram fazer o o
desmame deixaram de tomar os
medicamentos pesados tiveram noites de
sono perfeita e a depressão foi embora
minha mãe é um caso desse minha mãe ela
tinha depressão ela chorava ela não
conseguia nem pegar uma vassoura nem
lavar um copo ela se sentia inválida
porque ela não conseguia fazer nada e
ela pessa quer produzir dela era
reacional às dores que ela tinha
provavelmente né exato É mas eh a gente
já recebeu vários relatos de pessoas com
depressão então
Eh se fori realmente causado por isso eh
pode ter grande Chan de reversão é
porque existe depressões que são
exclusivamente inflamatórias não é como
às vezes se diz aí Alguns meios que ah
só um desequilíbrio dos
neurotransmissores não tem depressão que
não é a falta de ser não é falta de
neuro adrenalina ou excesso de
eh de outro neurotransmissores citatório
nada disso e é pura inflamação cerebral
certo então nesses casos eu acredito que
pode até acontecer de uma pessoa rever
ter uma depressão com hidrogênio agora
se tiver outros componentes parte
emocional essa pessoa realmente tiver
uma outras condições Pode ser que
melhore mas não vai melhorar aí 100% uma
pergunta interessante aqui também e tá
quer saber qual que é a relação de
ozônio e hidrogênio então O ozônio é um
agente oxidante tá ele oxida o organismo
aí você vai perguntar mas para que que
eu quero oxidar o organismo tem várias
razões para você oxidar o organismo
dependendo da concentração de ozônio ele
vai ser ele vai ter efeito
antiinflamatório também também vai ter
efeito analgésico se for uma
concentração mais alta de ozônio ele vai
ter efeito de matar bactérias vírus tá
pela oxidação que ele provoca porém como
é que O ozônio atua como
antiinflamatório porque na verdade o
ozônio oxida o organismo e o próprio
organismo reage ao ozônio aumentando a
atividade antioxidante então
Eh Pode parecer estranho mas o ozônio
ele atua ao contrário ele provoca
oxidação e a reação do organismo é que
vai ter efeito antiinflamatório no caso
hidrogênio a ação é direta não é
indireta como do ozônio então é uma boa
combinação por exemplo se você fizer um
um dia o ozônio estressar um pouquinho o
seu organismo e no dia seguinte você
usar o hidrogênio pode ser uma boa eu
não faria os dois juntos no mesmo dia
porque um vai ficar brigando com o outro
vai querer oxidar e outro vai querer
antioxid mas certamente ajudaria você
fazer o uso de hidrogênio para
fibromialgia e e a falar também sobre
baon e outras doenças neurodegenerativas
Com certeza o hidrogênio ajuda nisso
também tá quer acrescentar alguma coisa
É eu tenho até um vídeo de um um senhor
inalando hidrogênio ele parou de ele tem
par tinha né Parkinson aí tem outro
detalhe eh em relação a ao ozônio e
hidrogênio né todo profissional da saúde
que trabalha com ozônio a maioria
suplementa o paciente porque tem que
entrar com suplementação para que o
terreno biológico do paciente depois
tenha condiçõ de receber o ozônio senão
mu das vezes ele vai piorar o quadro
clínico do paciente tamb o ozone que não
atividade física você tá estressando seu
organismo uma atividade física também
você estressa o seu organismo Qual que é
o benefício depois do stresse que o seu
corpo vai se recuperar e o ozônio Age
dessa forma o que você falou é perfeito
você tem que fazer um uma boa
suplementação porque senão a pessoa não
vai ter
eh como se diz bala na agulha não vai
ter bala na na cartucha para poder ah
reagir a ação do oxidativa do do ozônio
exatamente aí o que que os profissionais
estão fazendo eles entram primeiro com
hidrogênio porque é um suplemento melhor
que a glutationa que a vitamina n seca
assisti cisteína por ser uma molécula
pequena ele vai permear melhor ali ele
vai eh fazer o serviço de preparar o
terreno biológico muito mais rápido aí
depois de 4 horas você pode entrar com
ozônio porque se você entrar antes com o
ozônio eh por exemplo você usou o
hidrogênio e depois você usar o ozônio o
hidrogênio ele é tão antioxidante que
ele vai cortar totalmente o efeito do
ozônio mas eu faria o contrário e para
mim não faz muito sentido fazer estaria
primeiro é eu estressar primeiro e
depois eu ajudaria o corpo com a
antioxidação porque senão você tá
fazendo o contrário você tá antioxid
para depois oxidar entendeu e lógico
talvez tenha algum resultado prático bom
de fazer desse jeito aí mas pela lógica
eu acho que faria mais sentido fazer
primeiro ozônio e horas depois ou ou no
dia seguinte fazer o hidrogênio para
ajudar o organismo nesse processo de
isso chama-se hormese que é a reação do
organismo a uma agente estressor se é um
um estresse controlado que o organismo
já conhece ele vai responder bem né
Então esse esse mecanismo de
hormese faria mais sentido fazer o
hidrogeno junto com a própria resposta
natural do organismo antioxidante
né mas às vezes alguém pode ter um
artigo científico mostrando o contrário
ou ou não sei se é uma coisa puramente
empírica isso daí né é vale Vale lembrar
que a assim todo profissional tem que
fazer antes a anamnese né do paciente aí
ali sim ele aí já vai ter já o caminho
andado ali para para fazer assertivo né
os protocolos iso é aqui a Sara tá
perguntando sobre cino da ardena bocal
certamente você não conhece isso ou
conhece não não não conheço não conheço
eu tenho um vídeo sobre isso tá Sara
prente a Sara já assistiu e eu acredito
que sim viu Sara porque uma das causas
da ência bucal dacal é disbiose e não é
a única Tá mas é uma das causas op atias
periféricas também é uma causa e o
hidrogênio por ser antioxidante ele deve
ajudar sim na cim da da dência bucal
certo eh efeitos e Estudos do hidrogênio
no cérebro sim tem estudos mostrando que
ele tem efeito positivo na doença de
paxon aliás vamos falar um pouco sobre
esse assunto já que a pergunta é sobre
isso temos estudos mostrando os efeitos
neuroprotetores do hidrogênio
molecular por exemplo a solução Salina
rica em
hidrogênio mostrou prevenir a
neuroinflamação o stresse oxidativo em
modelos animais O que poderia resultar
em melhorias na disfunção de memória
então a capacidade do hidrogênio de
atravessar a barreira hematoencefálica
ou hematol fórica e proteger as células
cerebrais torna ele um candidato muito
interessante para tratamento obviamente
um tratamento com outras coisas em
conjunto para doenças
neurodegenerativas e paraa melhora da
função cognitiva Respondendo a sua
pergunta e você saa de depoimentos nesse
sentido também né
sim eh eu tenho até um vídeo do de um
senhor inalando hidrogênio aí mostra ele
antes e depois e é coisa rápida não foi
demorado não é claro que cada paciente
reage de uma maneira diferente cada
organismo é diferente tem pessoas que
tem um Parkinson mais avançado outras
estão inicializando Então tudo isso tem
que ser levado em
conta não sei se pode mostrar o vídeo
eh o vídeo da depois do depoimento é
isso é o Senhor inalando e ele acho que
sim é a gente tem que só evitar eh aqui
algumas coisas que você sabe P que é
porque Infelizmente o meu canal já é um
pouquinho famoso né e tem gente aí que
fica no pé da gente né enfim Então é
melhor não mostrar mas porque tem
menções lá Não não tem menções porém é
impacta né é impactante não não mas você
só tiver só Impacto não tem problema
nenhum agora aqui essa sua pergunta Rose
Cris eu acredito que tem uma pessoa aí
nos comentários tá que vai tá te dando
essa informação tá Dá uma olhada nos
comentários eu acredito que vai aparecer
um comentário aí com uns links aí que
vão responder a sua pergunta pode
mostrar o
vídeo vou pegar aqui
ó esse senhor aqui ele tava em uma
clínica foi levar esposa e aí o dono da
Clínica viu ele assim
ó ó a mão
dele aí o dono da Clínica pediu para ele
segurar com a outra mão para tentar
parar o
tremor aí tremeu as duas
mãos primeiro dia el inalando
hidrogênio a mão parou de
tremer meia
hora segundo
dia Ó que ele voltou a a
fazer voltou a mexer no
celular aí ele abandonou o
tratamento 40 dias depois a mão ele
voltou a tremer
sim sim é é importante dizer isso né que
é o tipo de coisa que você tem que fazer
uso constante né para ter os melhores
resultados tá de novo Júlio eu acredito
que vai aparecer aí um algum comentário
que vai te ajudar nesse sentido tá
Ah isso que já já respondemos viu Carlos
se você não pegou a resposta depois
Assista o vídeo gravado que vai tá a
resposta
eh por de 20 minutos 30 minutos de vídeo
a gente comentou Essa questão aí você
perguntando
tá tem um comentário aqui do Valdemar
sobre vida na
fazenda Tenho minhas dúvidas sobre tal
assunto qual assunto valel não entendi
Qual sua pergunta você entendeu
aí Ah eu acho que
el tomava água de poço né só que aí a
falta de nutrientes porque eu citei lá o
magnésio né falta de nutrientes que pode
acarretar a outros
problemas sim Roseli eu acredito que
você vai achar isso no e algum
comentário aí que vai aparecer aí
na no vídeo Ok
eh eu acho que ela tá perguntando da
pastilha né aquela que você
mostrou
Ahã então tem pessoas perguntando sobre
a
pastilha tem um comentário aqui da Helen
tá Pessoal vocês que querem saber sobre
onde encontrar a pastilha Onde encontrar
o aparelho do do gás o aparelho que
hidrogen água a a Helen Brandão que tá
aí no na Live tá comentando tá sobre
onde encontrar tudo bem
ã olha aqui o depoimento Dr Ana Paula
ontem hoje dois copos por dia o sabor é
tranquilo não tem é o sabor é neutro não
fica diferente o sabor a urina ficou
mais e mais quantidade ex o hidrogênio
ele não tem cheiro não tem cor e quando
você inala por exemplo ele não altera o
sabor da água né quando você inala deixa
eu pegar aqui o o
cter vou abrir esse cter
aqui você tá inalando você não sente
nada É como se você tivesse sendo
enganado mas se você pegar esse catéter
e você colocar num copo d'água você vai
ver borbulhar Por que que isso acontece
o o hidrogênio ele é muito mais muito
mais leve que o gás
oxigênio Então essa leveza faz com que
você não sentisse nada existem
equipamentos de 150 ml de hidrogênio por
minuto até 3 l por minutos e até no de 3
l por minuto você não sente um vento
como se fosse inalar com oxigênio você
não vê fumacinha você não vê cor não tem
cheiro porém se você pegar o catéter e
pôr na água você vai ver ele
borbulhar
beleza Olha só outro depoimento Dr Ana
Paula aqui uso da água para limpar
feridas ticara de matoses E aí você tem
algum relato sobre isso sim eh vári as
pessoas eh quando elas têm alguma
queimadura ou algum machucado quando
você lava com a água hidrogenada aquela
inflamação que poderia vir prejudicar a
cicatrização ela é contida por exemplo
existem países de primeiro mundo que
quando tem um acidente de trânsito a
ambulância já chega com hidrogênio e
oxigênio para o acidentado inalar por
quê vai evitar greng grenas amputações
então diminui o nível de eh e causa ali
de inflamação então e esses países já
fazem isso então a pessoa que lavar a
mão com essa água que machucou que
queimou ela vai ter uma cicatrização
mais rápida você quer fazer um
comentário sobre o nerd da química que
que não sei qual foi a intenção do se
comentário mas era bom você comentar a
respeito disso então muitas pessoas
falam que o hidrogênio não se dissolve
na água por quê Porque essas pessoas
elas acreditam que por ser um gás volar
ele passa e vai embora só que eu queria
que essa pessoa pegasse um medidor de
orp e ela visse o que acontece ela
pegasse o medidor de partículas por
bilhão e ela vê o que acontece se o
aparelho ele tem o nível de Pureza onde
os artigos aonde as análises de gases
mostra que só sai hidrogênio e do outro
lado só oxigênio molecular que é o mesmo
dos cilindros que usam em hospitais como
é que a água ela passa a ter 1 e 100
partículas 5000 partículas por bilhão
como é que a água positiva ela passa ser
uma água negativa se existem laudos e
existem cientistas no mundo inteiro
provando da água Salina Salina rica
hidrogênio e do gás hidrogênio então eu
eu prefiro acreditar nos fatos que eu
vejo presencialmente eu tenho quase mais
de 6.000 depoimentos de pessoas que
tiveram benef com a água ou inalando e
também os artigos científicos que foram
feitos por cientistas renomados do mundo
inteiro médicos estudiosos que passam a
vida inteira se dedicando a novas
terapias integrativas do que acreditar
por exemplo em uma pessoa que fala que
não se dissolve em água então a questão
é o seguinte os artigos estão aí eu já
fui vos tem esse livro que eu comentei
esse livro publicado que é excelente
livro sobre hidrogênio e outra coisa
além dos artigos e do do livro A gente
tem aí os depoimentos das pessoas que
foram beneficiadas né então ess pode
falar essas essas pessoas Doutor
desculpa que eu te cortei elas só passam
a acreditar por exemplo E se alguém
falasse para mim há TRS anos atrás que a
minha mãe ia ter benefício tomando água
eu eu não ia acreditar mas aí quando eu
vi um artigo eu vi o sofrimento e eu vi
com os meus olhos o que aconteceu na
vida
dela eu comecei a acreditar e eu não
parei mais de acreditar agora por
exemplo desculpa Pode falar
Pode tem o Sérgio do tem o Sérgio do Rio
de Janeiro que o PSA de próstata dele
tava
371 chegando no osso o médico olhou para
ele e Falou sem chance aqui já era Olhou
lá metástase espalhada no corpo
inteiro semanas tomando a água foi só o
que ele mudou na vida dele ele tava
fazendo uso da água e de zeólita o que
que aconteceu o PSA caiu para oito em
três semanas a vida dele inteira ele
tomava água comum o que que ele fez de
diferente água hidrogenada o PSA caiu
para oito hoje tá em zero não precisou
fazer Raspagem da próstata não precisou
operar tá aí então queria comentar além
desse caso que você falou aí do PS que
caiu bruscamente é que assim existe um
site que eu uso muito ele de referência
chama-se examine.com lá é um pessoal que
só faz curadoria de estudo científico
então eles pegam os estudos classificam
estudos de alta qualidade média
qualidade e baixa qualidade e eles fazem
uns resumos então é uma equipe de
cientistas que ficam analisando vários
estudos em nutrição e eles têm uma
sessão lá no exame.com só sobre
hidrogênio Então se hidrogênio não fosse
uma coisa séria eles não colocariam lá
Posso garantir para vocês porque eles
são até um pouquinho exagerados na no
Rigor científico sabe então hidrogen já
tá lá como uma das sessões do exam.com
então é uma coisa que tem sim ciência
sólida por trás OK agora
eh enfim entendo a relutância do nerd da
química né e e realmente eu não sou um
especialista em química inorgânica para
para assim detalhar mais informações
sobre essa questão da da dissolução ou
não né
ã aqui tem alguém perguntando sobre
gastrite e
refluxo refluxo tem um ex-jogador de
futebol o nome dele é Macedo e ele jogou
no São Paulo ele sofria com isso quando
ele começou a tomar água hidrogenada o a
primeira coisa que ele fez foi falar
cara é que a gente vai reunindo todos os
depoimentos né a gente tem um banco de
dados parou ele não tem mais ele sentia
aquela voltar aquela queimação parou não
quer dizer que vai curar a gastrite todo
mundo
tá tudo que eu e Marcel est falando aqui
obviamente A tá falando dos casos que
teve os melhores resultados Tá mas
detalhe cada caso é um caso pode
acontecer que você não tem esse esse
benefício mas com certeza melhorar vai
para ajudar a melhorar pode falar racel
é outro detalhe que eu esqueci de falar
é que assim o Sérgio que eu comentei do
PSA de próstata eu falei que foi só o
hidrogênio e e a única coisa que ele fez
de diferente mas eu vou me corrigir aqui
o que que ele fez de diferente ele
passou ele parou de comer churrasco
pizza refrigerante cerveja ou seja tudo
que inflamava o corpo dele ele parou de
consumir E aí ele tava consumindo só
coisas saudáveis ele teve uma dieta
antioxidante então não adianta nada por
exemplo a pessoa achar que vai ser o
salvador da pátria se ela também não
fizer a parte dela por exemplo a gente
sabe que as células cancerígenas elas se
alimentam de Açúcar então ah eu vou vou
tomar hidrogênio para apagar essa
inflamação para transformar o ambiente
ácido em o ambiente alcalino para trazer
um benefício para mim só que aí eu vou
comer um monte de doce então eu vou est
brigando esse vai est tentando ajudar e
o outro vai e destrói todo o serviço
desse então a pessoa tem que fazer a
parte dela também perfeito tem uma
pessoa que tá comentando aqui que meu
som tá ruim mas quando a gente começou a
Live n o Marcelo falou que tava me
ouvindo bem você tá me ouvindo bem né
Marcelo tô te ouvindo perfeito pessoal
eh além do Sérgio Rocha que comentou
aqui vocês estão me ouvindo bem Vocês
estão me entendendo sim ou não porque eu
tenho outro microfone tá aliás tenho um
monte de microfone aqui eu quis usar
esse aqui porque ele é fone e microfone
também tá então por favor comentem se o
meu áudio está ruim tá ou se é só o
problema lá do setup do Ségio
ã Então pessoal essa pergunta aqui a
Helen tá fazendo comentários a respeito
da procura os comentários da Helen
Brandão que ela tá falando sobre isso ok
e como usar para uma pessoa com síndrome
nefrótica eh tem que tomar cuidado só se
a pessoa tem suficiência renal grave ela
vai ter que fazer restrição hídrica tá
Então na verdade você vai ter que seguir
as orientações do nefrologista quanto de
líquido que essa pessoa pode tomar por
dia tá se ela tomar líquido demais ela
vai ficar eh com uma piora da condição
dela porque ela vai ficar mais inchada
vai aumentar pressão arterial e se for
uma pessoa que faz diálise né então tem
que tomar cuidado com essa questão pode
falar Marcelo não é que tinha um
bichinho aqui tava levantando a r nem
esola é e qual a quantidade de água que
devemos tomar por dia tá você tem uma
recomendação de quantos ml da água
hidrogenada 35 ml por peso é por quilo
por exemplo e sempre que eu sentir sede
eu ia tomar água comum eu posso
substituir por essa outra água e o ideal
é tomar você faz lá o a multiplica lá os
35 ml vai eu tenho
e 8 6 kg aí vou colocar 86 X 35 ml eu já
ten a quantidade certa que eu tenho que
tomar é claro que tem pessoas que eh
elas praticam esportes ela tem uma
necessidade maior e se você tomar muita
mas muita água hidrogenada você vai
passar mal não por conta do hidrogênio
mas sim por conta da quantidade de água
que é a mesma coisa se você tomasse a
água sem hidrogênio você passa mal pelo
excesso e não pelo porque tem o
hidrogênio
ali muito bem muito bem
ten aqui um depoimento do Juaci eu senti
mais disposição douo melhor hoje desde
começou tomar o
hidrogênio Maria milva tá dizendo eu
quero conhecer está conhecendo agora com
a gente assiste a Live anterior também
viu que tá lá no canal Procura lá no
canal a Live anterior que tem mais
informação lá também
e deixa eu ver se alguém já respondeu
aqui sobre o
áudio o som do doutor está baixo
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo melhorar isso
pera aí
tã acho se se eu cancelar o reduzir o o
coiso aqui talvez melhor pera aí e agora
pessoal me diga como é que tá agora tá
bom eu dei uma corrigida aqui não
Jandira falou que tá ótimo o som Ixe eu
tô agora tô confuso não sei se tá bom ou
se tá ruim agora ficou ficou bom e muito
alto tá muito alto tá
exagerado tá estourando aqui então deixa
eu baixar um pouco aqui tá estourando
vamos lá e agora que que você diz tá bom
tá tá bem melhor tá vou deixar aqui
assim então pronto
eh Então é isso acho que tem uma
variação
de Alfredo falou que melhorou a Tatiana
falou que melhorou mas tinha gente
falando que tava bom sim né
Ah deixa eu voltar aqui nas
perguntas qual o efeito do hidrogênio no
tratamento do Câncer efeito
antiinflamatório especialmente
antioxidante né Isso vai ter efeito
anticancerígeno eh fala dos depoimentos
que você conhece aí sobre isso o que
mais deixou a gente feliz e impactado é
que as pessoas que fazem a quimioterapia
e usam o hidrogênio molecular elas rel
que elas não tiveram anemia não tiveram
enjoos vômitos e não ficaram
debilitadas pessoas que o o ca tava 8900
e pouco em 8 meses usando o hidrogênio o
ca baixou para
143 e isso tudo comprovando o exame
antes o exame Depois os médicos falam
que essa pessoa tem que ser estudada
pela NASA porque era para ela tá acamada
e o ca dela de 8000 pouco quase 99000
baixou para
142 em pouco tempo e os médicos tinham
dado para ela 8 meses de vida já faz do
anos que ela usa o hidrogênio tem um
depoimento aqui também da uma pessoa da
veralúcia que usou o cravo tava com
cravo muito inflamado usou antibiótico
junto com o hidrogênio e fechou após 10
dias pergunta se ajuda na aterosclerose
ajuda sim porque a aterosclerose é um
processo inflamatório e também ativo que
acontece na parede das artérias tá então
vai ajudar sim na aterosclerose
Ahã para de doença autoimune ajuda Na
remissão e para disbiose disbiose já
comentou que sim né ajuda na disbiose
intestinal e doença autoimune certamente
vai ajudar porque parte do processo
autoimune é inflamatório e também
estresse oxidativo tá curar é aito que
não mas vai ajudar na doeça autoimune
você tem sim a gente falou que da
artrite reumat ajuda bastante né você
sabe se a dor crônica da sua mãe era
Artrite reumatoide ou qual queer a era
Artrite reumatoide e os dedos da mão
dela já estava inchando para trofi já
então no caso dela reverteu tudo o
detalhe interessante ela ela tava usando
já
uns seis 7 meses e aí ela foi pra casa
da minha tia e ela não levou o
equipamento
E aí ela ia ficar dois meses lá eu falei
vixe minha mãe vai voltar morrendo ela
voltou normal ou seja com a minha mãe
aconteceu que o próprio organismo dela
reestruturou eh tem um artigo científico
que fala que o a flora intestinal que é
a microbiota pode produzir até 12 l de
hidrogênio por dia quando a pessoa tá
saudável quando a pessoa tá na
eubiose quando ela não tá na na eubiose
ela tá na disbiose disbiose é muito mais
bactérias más do que as boas e isso
acarreta essas outras doenças aí o que
que aconteceu com a minha mãe Eh o A
microbiota dela passou ela ficou na
eubiose então quando ela tava na minha
tia esses dois meses eu pensei que ela
ia voltar com dor só que ela voltou
normal por quê ela não tava com disbiose
ela tava na eubiose então o próprio
organismo fabrica nós somos máquinas
perfeitas que Deus construiu porém no
meio do caminho poluição eletromagnética
radiações celulares 5g eh má alimentação
vida sedentária isso destrói a máquina
perfeita e o hidrogênio ele restaurou e
por isso minha mãe não voltou a ter
essas dores eh doença autoimune como a a
de pele lá como é que chama meu pai
psoríase
psoríase um rapaz lá de Portugal Ele
entrou em contato né falando assim olha
o hidrogênio psoriaas e tal eu achei um
artigo científico mandei para para ele
aí ele começou a usar junto com outros
eh manipulados E aí ele mandou um relato
falando que ele não tem mais por quê
Porque a o hidrogênio ele ele reverte
algumas doenças autoimune E aí ele
potencializa o uso de outras terapias
então por exemplo a pessoa ela tá
fazendo quimioterapia ela vai continuar
fazendo a quimioterapia ela vai
continuar tomando os remédios porém o
hidrogênio ele vai est Preparando o
terreno biológico para absorver tudo que
precisa para combater as doenças então
ele é um potencializador de outras
terapias
perfeito eu acho que a pergunta aqui é
se vai ter que utilizar o hidrogênio pro
resto da vida eu acho que é uma boa
ideia usar pro resto da vida porque você
tá sempre sendo exposta a estresses
oxidativos inflamatórios né então se
você puder usar o a vida inteira com
certeza é uma ótima pedida assim como
você vai ter que comer a vida inteira
beber a vida inteira se exercitar a vida
inteira dormir direito a vida inteira
controlar o estresse com técnicas
meditativas a vida inteira né Eliseu
essa pergunta já foi respondida é a
resposta é sim tá
eh eu não conheço contraindicações
eh de cabeça aqui a não ser que você
utilize um hidrogênio muito concentrado
na F inalatória aí tem contraindicações
que pode explodir o equipamento porque o
hidrogênio é um gás eh que pode ser
inflamado né ele pode eh agora fora essa
contraindicação de você não usar o
hidrogênio concentrado na inalação que
pode causar uma explosão eu não conheço
outra contraindicação Você conhece
Marcelo o o hidrogênio quando a pessoa
tiver inalando hidrogenado uma água
Jamais ela pode ficar acendendo o
isqueiro próximo ou a pessoa na cozinha
fazendo comida com catéter inalando se o
catéter esbarrar no fogo ali no fogo
fogão por Acidente ou se a pessoa
acender o cigarro enquanto enala ela vai
causar uma explosão porém os
equipamentos eles têm uma concentração
que é o gás é volátil por exemplo se tá
produzindo o gás aqui ou acender o
isqueiro aqui eu não vou explodir porque
ele vai se diluir rapidamente porém se
eu colocar em cima vai explodir então a
gente recomenda quando a pessoa tiver
inalando evitar ficar com fogo próximo
porque mas os aparelhos eles têm
válvulas de retenção que cortam a chama
para que não não haja esse esse caos aí
de explosão perfeito então é o que eu
mas não existe é não existe efeito
colateral é só o problema da Explosão né
em excesso no organismo o hidrogênio vai
virar pequenas minúsculas gotículas de
água perfeito você tem alguma
experiência no c19 só fala C1 para
evitar o o vídeo de sofrer algum sim tá
É o que a gente mais recebe por exemplo
a Elisete de Minas Gerais ela chegava na
casa dela no portão da casa dela aí
faltava fôlego ela tava com sequelas
então ela não conseguia nem sair e nem
voltar para casa ela só andava até o
portão aí faltava fôlego quando ela
começou a usar o hidrogênio ela mandou
depoimento falando que ela fez 7 km de
caminhada sem se cansar outra pessoa
também que o pai na Bahia eh precisavam
levantar Senhor deid três pessoas para
ele ir no banheiro fazer as atividades
físicas dele Tipo fisiológicas eh quando
ele começou a usar o hidrogênio todo
mundo tomou um susto porque ele pulou da
cama sozinho ou seja o pulmão é pessoas
com efizema pulmonar tiveram benefícios
mandaram depoimentos então a gente não
conhece assim ainda e porque eh 70% das
doenças são causadas por oxidação então
ó existem doenças por eu eu acredito que
só por três motivos parasitas o
emocional que o corpo carrega traumas
que evoluem para problemas eh dores e
também por eh oxidação oxidação traumas
eh e parasitas se a pessoa não tem
parasita se ela faz por exemplo uma
terapia neural para fazer um reset e e
também uso o hidrogênio para antioxid
dificilmente ela vai não vai ter
benefício em alguma patologia
bem Jandira eu começaria usando água
hidrogenada né eu começaria comprando a
garrafinha hidrogenada a água e depois
que você sentir que tem uma segurança no
no método talvez você poderia comprar um
gerador aí de de gases tá para fazer a
inalação com hidrogênio ou pode começar
também comprando o a pastilha
né sim a pastilha é uma maneira barata
eficiente da pessoa levar hidrogênio
magnésio trata marítima
eh tem turmalina negra tem vários
minerais que vão potencializar a água né
então a água vai ficar literalmente
igual a água de Okinawa no Japão
perfeito pergunta aqui hidrogênio ajuda
no lupus Com certeza ajuda no lupus
elect tomatose porque é uma doença
autoimune que tem um componente
infamatório importante tá eh eu tenho
Hum Tem um depoimento do
a a mulher ela tinha um equipamento que
ela tava levando pro pai e no meio do
caminho ela parou na casa da irmã que
tinha lupos que tem lupos E aí ela
precisava levar o equipamento pro pai só
que naquela noite que ela ficou na casa
da irmã a irmã relatou para ela aí a
irmã usou o equipamento ela relatou que
ela não teve mais tantas dores porque
são dores terríveis e ela conseguiu
dormir melhor só que no outro dia ela
teve que levar o equipamento pro pai
dela
perfeito
eh Você conhece algum médico que que
trabalha com essa tecnologia em
Joinville ou
Marcelo como eu separei os setores é
assim eu eu não eu não tenho mais esse
esses contatos assim do dos
profissionais Mas eu posso ver sim eu
posso posso ver com o pessoal e E aí a
gente consegue fazer o levantamento Eu
também de cabeça eu não eu não lembro
não né E que que você você diz sobre
isso
aqui é um detox que por exemplo se você
fizer uma
desparasitação os parasitas por exemplo
existe zaper usado é tipo desenvolvido
pela dout Uda Clark a doutora canadense
ele desparasita eletronicamente aí você
faz a desparasitação seu corpo vai est
cheio de toxinas o que que o hidrogênio
vai fazer ele vai ajudar a desintoxicar
sua células fazer um detox dessas
toxinas então ele vai ajudar a
potencializar a recuperação depois de
uma
desparasitação você sabe de casos aí no
grupo que você acompanha sobre nódulo de
[Música]
mama eu sei de boas recuperaç ah de de
por exemplo tinha uma mulher que
estourou a ferida né do câncer de mama e
ela começou a lavar com a água saturada
em hidrogênio e ajudou na na ferida
porém eh existem outras terapias né que
a gente nem pode citar aqui que foram eh
mais eficazes porém é é é impossível
falar nas redes sociais é a gente tem
que tomar muito cuidado hoje em dia
pessoal
eh olha só a explicação muito boa do
Marcelo aqui para responder o doutor
química lá né o hidrogênio realmente não
se dissolve caso contrário você poderia
vender água com hidrogênio engarrafado
exatamente isso que ele falou no começo
da Live né não consegue manter esse
hidrogênio muito tempo ele escapa né Por
exemplo ó
eh eu eu vou vender uma água hidrogenada
aí na na lata aí
hidrogeneo esse gás ele não vai se
prender ele vai ficar aqui ele ele Aos
aos poucos ele vai saindo da água e ele
vai ficar aqui porque ele é volátil vai
ficar no espaço que não tem água aí a
pessoa recebe a água opa vou tomar
água o gás foi embora aí a água tá
oxidante então ela não vai ter benefício
então o mais ideal é você fabricar a sua
água e tomar na hora porque a o gás
ainda vai tá na água porque você fez na
hora aí o certo por exemplo a pessoa
comprou essas águas é ela pegar e ela
agitar bastante para de certa forma o
hidrogênio voltar ali para ficar entre
os espaços da molécula de
h2oi é fazer e consumir na mesma hora
para Justamente não ter esse problema do
gás sumir né exato É e a Val dizendo que
comprou uma garrafinha que veio do Japão
um amigo trouxe para mim será
diferenciado das daqui depende né
Marcelo ó eu vou eu vou explicar cadê
eu vou vou dar um um feedback para vocês
aqui do que é certo e o que é errado
quer
ver tem tem uma uma membrana que
ela ela tem a o Polo positivo e o polo
negativo em
cima e essa membrana ela ela acaba tipo
liberando metais pesados na água Deixa
eu ver se eu acho
aqui eu vou mostrar a foto aí vai ficar
facinho
de arquivos
eu não tô achando mas é eu vou vou
explicar de uma maneira assim lúdica se
você olhar a membrana aonde sai o
hidrogênio na sua garrafa se ela tiver e
como se fosse um labirinto assim ó
é um uma comeia tipo um labirinto ali é
a parte positiva e a parte negativa ela
não presta se ela não tiver um descarte
de oxigênio embaixo ela não presta agora
se ela tiver um descarte de oxigênio e a
membrana
dela deixa eu ver aqui se vai dar para
ver deixa eu
colocar aqui pera
aí aqui a gente tá vendo uma tela
interiça lá dentro ó é como se fosse uma
rede isso significa que é só um polo é o
polo negativo agora se pera aí pera aí
não era isso que eu queria fazer deixa
eu deixa eu trocar por você aqui pronto
vai isso ó aqui ó eu tô só tem uma rede
lá dentro ó só tem uma tela Isso
significa que é um polo só e é o polo
negativo por que que eu sei que é o polo
negativo porque a água ficou com RP
negativo então aqui eu não desgasto
nunca esse Polo e eu vou est levando
hidrogênio puro pra minha água e aqui
atrás ela vai ter que ter essa saída de
oxigênio porque na eletrólise É é tem
que ter essa saída de oxigênio porque se
não tiver aí o que que vai acontecer se
não tiver a a saída aqui na água eu vou
est levando hidrogênio e oxigênio e vou
est levando metal pesado pra minha água
então é a maneira de você saber se sua
garrafinha é boa ou não perfeito Tem
gente perguntando aqui tem uma pessoa tá
a Helen el ela divulgou um link aí tá
Teca dá uma olhada no comentário da
Helen Brandão tá bom
eh tem gente perguntando espondilite
aqui lante ajuda sim tá aqui é outra
doença autoimune Ok Ahã isso aqui eu não
sei talvez o Marcelo saiba tem alguma
coisa a ver aí o água de Caldas Novas qu
Caldas Novas em Goiás sim pô eh o que
que qu o que que tem que se fazer a
gente estudando a gente descobriu que só
existem cinco lugares no planeta que tem
essa Nascente com água antioxidante que
é por conta dos minerais que tem naquela
região
então uma maneira seria pegar essa água
comprar um medidor de orp E aí através
do orp se der negativo a gente sabe que
tem propriedades antioxidantes Então
seria uma água existem águas medicinais
por conta da se águas termais ajudam em
fungos dores Porém para consum a gente
entende que só tem esses cinco lugares é
Himalaia no tibé em Roma e na Itália e
em okina no Japão os outros dois lugares
eu não lembro agora mas só existem cinco
nascen se eu não me engano duas já
secaram então só tem três
agora
perfeito então ô Tatiana você pode
começar tomando água hidrogenada e
depois você pode pensar e usar um
aparelho que hidrogena gases né Para
você fazer a
inalação certo
ã eu acho que já estamos com 1 hora e
me0 de Live né Eu acho que tá bom da
gente pensar em encerrar
né Tem bastante tempo já o João Paulo
agradecendo pela Live Pessoal vocês TM
mais
perguntas eu pensei também em falar mais
sobre o hidrogo mas como tem muito tempo
de Live eu acho respondemos bastante
perguntas
e depois quem for assistir a versão
gravada vai ficar com preguiça de
assistir né pelo pelo tempo de duração
do vídeo pode falar Marcelo é só para
dar uma resumida ó eu vou ser bem rápido
o o hidrogênio é uma forma de repor
elétrons nós somos seres elétricos O que
acontece se nós tivermos entre Men 25 MV
a men 40 m nós estamos saudáveis porém
durante o dia se a gente tem um momento
de stress no serviço a gente começa a
ficar -2 vai eu tava -25 fiquei -20 se
alguém me deu um susto eu me assustei e
aí aquele susto eu perdi elétrons se eu
tô na frente do ar condicionado o dia
inteiro ele tá me roubando elétrons as
lâmpadas de led rouba elétrons Eu tenho
um boleto para pagar e eu não tenho
dinheiro para pagar isso vai roubando
elétrons vai chegar uma hora que meu
corpo vai ficar com carga positiva e aí
eu é o terreno biológico perfeito para
propagação das doenças o que que o
hidrogênio faz ele repõe elétrons ele
devolve o elétrons para você ficar com a
carga negativa e aí você ter como
controlar seu próprio organismo vai
fazer o papel de de controlar essas
doenças porque ele vai est saudável
Então a maneira fácil da pessoa entender
o que o hidrogênio vai fazer na saúde
ele vai te repor elétrons e esses
elétrons vai ser o que vai dar condições
paraas suas células estarem perfeitas
para combater qualquer
perfeito eu acho que não tem mais
perguntas pelo menos eu não tô achando
aqui acho que eu consegui ver
praticamente todos os comentários
pessoal novamente eu convido vocês
assistirem a Live anterior que eu falo
sozinho porque lá Eu também dei algumas
informações a mais da parte científica
essa Live que o objetivo era ser mais
prático era ser uma linguagem mais
simples do possível e aproveitar aí a
experiência do Marcelo os depoimentos
todos que ele conhece todo o
conhecimento que ele adquiriu e
consolidou ao longo desses anos então a
gente quis fazer uma coisa mais prática
mais eh Tete a Tete com vocês
respondendo mais perguntas por isso que
a gente pode não ter falado todas as
informações sobre o hidrogênio mas na
Live anterior tem mais informações a
jira também tá agradecendo
eh sim Marcelo eu fiz F comentários
sobre o benefício do hidrogênio tá e eu
fiz falei isso na Live anterior só que a
gente não pode fazer uma live de 5 horas
de duração tá Marcelo tá espero que você
entenda e caso você se você possa ir lá
na Live anterior e assistir é melhor Ok
bem pessoal Muito obrigado aí pelos
comentários pelo carinho pela
atenção então a gente se vê na próxima
Live Um abraço um beijo no coração de
vocês dá o seu alô aí Marcelo pro
pessoal aliás o seu Tchau pessoal então
quero agradecer a todos que ficaram
conosco até esse momento e e é isso
pessoal eu comecei a estudar hidrogênio
e não parei mais e eu tenho certeza que
quando você começar a estudar sobre
hidrogênio você também não vai querer
parar de estudar um grande abraço a
todos e Desejo
saúde tchau tchau pessoal até a próxima